is the expanse about to be saved again
but not by who we thought are there two
streaming services battling for this tv
show
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so a couple weeks ago i did a video
about how amazon were actually
storyboarding out a trilogy of movies
for the expanse
but i'm now being told that actually the
storyboarding process was only done for
amazon to a figure out how much it would
actually cost to produce this trilogy of
movies and b figure out if they could
even do the project justice in a movie
format whether the book could be
translated to a movie in any sort of
effective way
i'm now being told that actually amazon
are cooling their interest in this
because after looking into it and doing
the storyboarding and kicking it around
the office a little bit they're starting
to believe that one it would be too
expensive to produce and two they
couldn't do it justice anyway
so this leaves open for alcon now alcon
are a bad company that actually produce
the tv series they own the rights to the
expanse amazon are just the company that
bought it
now alkane are pretty good when it comes
to their contracts sci-fi who actually
initially commissioned this tv series
ended up cancelling it after the third
series at least in part because of the
contract they had with alcon they didn't
like the power alcon kept um
particularly when it comes to
distribution rights worldwide
sci-fi was spending a lot of money
producing this tv show and maybe not
getting the return they hoped because of
the contract they had with alcon
when amazon saved the tv show they made
sure they got worldwide distribution
rights and worldwide distribution rights
that they keep but alcon were again a
little bit savvy and we told that
actually part of the contract is that
amazon have the right to pick up the
seventh season but if they don't those
rights revert back to alcon and they are
then allowed to sell those rights on to
a second party
without any fees or penalties paid to
amazon
now amazon will still own the
distribution rates for the first six
seasons those aren't going anywhere
they're staying at amazon prime now
there is another contractual problem
that amazon have they were like i say
genuinely thinking about doing a trilogy
of movies but the contracts they have
with alcon are only for a tv series they
don't have any movie rights so this
would have required them to negotiate a
new contract with alcon now this is
something that could still happen but it
isn't very likely as again insiders are
telling me that alcon aren't
particularly keen to do that they would
much rather see a full-blowns tv series
something they can get much better
return on their dollar for than a
trilogy of movies so it looks like alcon
would prefer a tv series in which case
it doesn't look like amazon are going to
produce it so somebody else could
this opens the door to two big streamer
services one of those being netflix
now netflix actually had the
distribution rights to the first three
series of the expanse before
amazon came in
i saw the first three series of expanse
on netflix outside of the united states
that's where everybody saw the expanse
so netflix already has a working
relationship welcome they already have a
connection to the show and they reported
really good numbers with the expanse
when it was first on their network so
they would love to have the expanse back
now what they would actually do that and
how we would look we'll talk about in a
second because the second company that
is interested in this is actually hbo
max now as i said in my previous video
and i'm talking about babylon 5 and how
hbo max is considering taking that from
the cw hbo max is also considering the
expanse
now
alcon actually does have a working
relationship with warner brothers too
they produced several movies for warner
brothers and warner brothers have the
distribution rights for those and i'm
being told that warner brothers had
already made it known to alcon that if
the amazon
rights do return to them that they would
be very very interested in taking on
this project and producing three
television series that would go directly
to hbo max
so what would the tv series look like if
it did return
well for one i'm being told that it
would probably be
packaged a little bit differently their
hbo or netflix are going to want to have
a little bit of separation from the
other project the six original series
because those will still be being shown
on amazon they're going to want a little
bit a different they're going to want a
little bit of separation from those one
way they could do this is by actually
naming each series maybe directly after
the book or coming back with some like
expanse rising or something like that
having the title even just a little bit
different would give them a little bit
of separation from the first six series
and a little bit of separation from the
amazon product they're going to want to
make it in some ways their own
now there's also 30 years between book
six and book seven that allows them
again to have some changes some
stylistic changes some actor changes and
so on new characters new people new team
developing and a new look in some ways
but they're gonna want to at the same
time keep it as close to the original as
humanly possible so that it doesn't
alienate the existing fans because this
is really a cult tv show the people that
love the expanse
love the expanse i get comments all the
time on my channel saying that expanse
is actually the best sci-fi we've had on
our tv screens in years and i don't
necessarily disagree with them as a
grown-up sci-fi tv show you can't really
do much better than the expanse
so to just to clarify that though
they're going to want it to be different
in some ways but they're going to want
to keep the original feel and the
original look so that it doesn't
alienate the existing fans
guys what do you think do you think the
expanse could be saved again
do you think amazon are fools for
letting this series go and if it were to
go to hbo max and netflix would the
amazon executives be kicking themselves
please leave a comment and tell me
exactly what you think
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps me out and
if you want to become a fully fledged
sidetracker and support the channel you
can hit the join button below
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time